monde a dit je vous ai laissé des petits
indices parce que vraiment 2021 c'est
l'année où pour moi tout a changé
[Musique]
il salue les gens noirs écran c'est
françois pour la dernière vidéo de
l'année aujourd'hui j'avais envie de
m'adresser directement à vous expliquer
plein de petites choses qui ont changé
cette année que j'ai disséminer un petit
peu tout au long de l'année donc l'idée
de cette vidéo c'est de faire un petit
peu le lien entre toutes ces choses pour
que vous voyez un petit peu la ligne
directrice et l'évolution d'un vidéaste
au final puisque c'est ça que je vais
vous raconter c'est ça que je fais sur
youtube depuis des années maintenant et
je pense clairement que ça va vous
intéresser alors j'ai rangé les choses
dans un ordre à peu près aléatoire sauf
la fin où j'ai gardé les trucs qui fâche
un petit peu le meilleur pour la fin
c'est vrai que toi même tu sais et on va
commencer par le commencement c'est à
dire la chose qui a fait que j'ai eu une
illumination à dire bah tiens qu'est ce
que j'ai envie de faire vraiment sur
youtube et aussi bas dans ma vie
professionnelle de vidéastes et ça c'est
d'arriver en début d'année 2021 et c'est
tout simplement la websérie alors si
vous suivez la chaîne régulièrement vous
avez vu que cette année et je me suis
lancé dans un gros projet avec une
équipe de malades il me serre est un
petit peu originale puisqu'elle mêlée de
la fiction et du tuto des explications
sur le monde de la vidéo où vous l'avez
pas vous encourage à cliquer sur le lien
qui s'affiche ici pour aller
immédiatement la voir puisque ça a été
un travail de malade des mois et des
mois et des mois de travail mais surtout
ça m'a permis de comprendre que vraiment
la fiction c'était quelque chose que
j'aimais beaucoup pour une raison très
simple c'est que on travaille en équipe
et ça vraiment cette année j'ai trouvé
une équipe de malades mari était déjà là
avec moi et mes déjà beaucoup et est
clairement balle est indispensable mais
clairement cette collaboration avec ben
et guillaume elle est allée au delà de
la web série puisqu'on a fait encore
plein de choses il ya eu avec ben
notamment les nomades session il ya des
clips qui sont en cours de tournage avec
guillaume aussi bref on a une petite
équipe là qui est vraiment très très
sympa et avec laquelle je compte
travailler énormément en 2021 d'ailleurs
on prépare des choses un petit peu on va
aller dans des lieux je dis rien je dis
rien mais vous allez voir c'est voilà si
je vous le dis parce que ces bouquets et
parce que parce que ces prêts et que ça
va être fait que j'en suis sûr
donc restez à l'affût l'autre chose qui
a changé un petit peu ma façon de voir
les choses et là c'est un petit peu plus
technique alors on dit souvent que le
matériel ne fait pas la vidéo et c'est
totalement vrai entendu si on veut faire
deux belles vidéos il faut du travail du
talent des gens avec qui travailler bref
c'est pas une histoire de matos mais
cette année vous l'avez vu j'ai beaucoup
parlé de l'arrêt de komodo avec laquelle
je suis en train de filmer la
actuellement et cette caméra m'a fait
aussi comprendre plein de choses le
simple fait d'utiliser une caméra de
signer par rapport à mai dslr que
j'utilise d'habitude et que j'utilise
d'ailleurs le plus souvent on va pas se
mentir ça m'a fait penser un petit peu
les choses différemment mais les
contraintes a mené par la komodo me
donne envie aussi de faire d'autres
choses m'ont obligé à travailler
notamment sur la colorimétrie sur la
technique sur plein de choses que je
connaissais pas cette année et l'air de
rien c'est lié avec le premier point
c'est à dire que la partie fiction la
partie clip elle a été aussi un petit
peu conditionné par la commune depuis ce
que j'ai vu ce que je pouvais faire avec
et là encore ça change un petit peu la
donne c'est que cette caméra là je ne
peux pas faire du corporate je peux pas
faire du mariage même si j'en ai fait
une fois juste pour le kiff du coup
l'utilisation de cette caméra elle m'a
dirigé vers d'autres choses que j'ai
envie de faire notamment énormément de
clips parce que c'est quelque chose que
j'aime énormément faire à la base
j'étais musicien mon premier projet
professionnel c'était de faire de la
musique mais raide un petit peu brisé
puisque talent n'était pas forcément au
rendez vous mais le fait de faire du
clip et avec une caméra de signer ça me
permet de lier mais trois passions c'est
à dire le cinéma la musique et faire des
vidéos clairement c'est quelque chose
que j'ai envie de pousser encore plus
loin pour aller sortir des profs
vraiment qui me plaisent vraiment qui
m'éclate et guider dont je sois fier
j'ai éclaté avec mes autres caméras
aussi mais celle ci elle m'a amené un
petit peu plus loin le troisième point
qui a changé un petit peu les choses
cette année on y reviendra un petit peu
plus tard à la fin c'est youtube mais
c'est aussi tik tok vous allez
comprendre pourquoi le lien entre les
deux j'ai découvert la plateforme tik
tok cette année et je me suis mis de
manière relativement régulière parce que
je trouve que c'est une plateforme où il
ya encore de la place on peut encore
aller créer des choses un petit peu
nouvelles des choses qui soient pas déjà
vu même si le fond restera quand même
tel qu'il est mais dans la forme on peut
aller chercher quelque chose d'assez
créatif assez facilement assez
simplement sans se prendre la tête et
c'est une plate forme que j'ai vraiment
envie de penser l'année prochaine aussi
sans rentrer dans quelque chose de bas
de gamme vraiment aller à les pousser
tik tok sur ses retranchements et créer
des choses chouette au format vertical
et j'en ai fait d'ailleurs une vidéo
cette année qui avait reçu un accueil
assez intéressant d'ailleurs je vous
encourage à aller la voir elle s'affiche
elle aussi vraiment tik tok ça c'est un
truc pour 2022 où je pense que je vais
m'investir et essayer d'aller chercher
de la créativité là bas et là encore on
va dérouler le fil il ya une chose qui a
changé aussi cette année c'est la façon
dont je fais mes tuto et mes réveils ou
de matériel et ça clairement ça a changé
vous avez pu le voir il ya eu très peu
de vidéo cette année qui ont été justes
bah tiens j'ai du matos je le teste pour
youtube la façon de manger organiser les
choses c'est que je suis allé faire des
preuves tout simplement me pour mon
métier en côté pro et danser prod je
suis allé chercher un élément qui me
paraissait intéressant de vous partager
et en faire une vidéo youtube alors il
ya eu le bureau il ya eu le z9 il ya eu
plein de choses mais toutes ces choses
là et partez pas d'une envie ou d'un
besoin de faire une vidéo youtube elle
partait tout simplement d'une preuve que
je devais faire et j'en ai fait une
vidéo et pas l'inversé je cherchais pas
à parler d'un sujet donc j'allais filmer
des choses pour pouvoir illustrer mon
propos j'avais d'abord filmer des choses
il se passait des trucs intéressants et
je me suis dit tiens je vais en parler
aux gens sur le tube parce que ça peut
être intéressant et ça a clairement
c'est exactement ce que je compte faire
pour tout le reste de la vie de la
chaîne youtube au final si je trouve ça
beaucoup plus logique alors il y aura
peut-être des exceptions comme j'ai fait
notamment pour les pico mail j'ai reçu
le truc j'ai trouvé ça génial je me suis
dit tiens voilà je vais en parler aux
gens mais la plupart du temps
j'essaierai de partir de prod que je
vais faire pour vous parler de points
spécifiques je trouve intéressant et
pertinent de vous partager en 2021 il ya
eu aussi un rapport aux marques qui a
changé pour moi j'ai fait me semble deux
vidéos sponso et c'était pour financer
en fait la websérie mais j'ai fait aussi
une vidéo qui disaient que je ne
souhaitais plus faire de vidéos
sponsorisées à j'en reparlerai un petit
peu dans la dernière partie celle sur
les éditeurs pour vous expliquer aussi
des choses par rapport à ça mais je ne
souhaite plus travailler avec des
marques de façon rémunéré je travaillais
avec des marques pour avoir du matériel
qui va m'intéresser comme c'était le cas
notamment pour le test du z9 ça
m'intéressait d'avoir toutes les
fonctionnalités du 16 9 pour filmer un
clip et donc j'ai contacté une icône
pour pouvoir avoir du matériel et
essayer mais en aucun cas je été
contacté par la marque pour faire la
promo avec un script avec des choses à
dire celle inverse et ça je vais le
continuer aussi c'est à dire que je vais
contacter peut-être des marques quand il
ya un truc qui m'intéresse peut-être
qu'il ya des marques qui me contactera
pour proposer des produits et si ces
choses là vraiment je vois un intérêt
dans le monde boulot de tous les jours à
savoir filmer des trucs cool là
éventuellement je dirais oui mais ça
restera dans tous les cas des tests
objectifs c'est à dire mon avis
uniquement et je refuserais
catégoriquement tout ce qui sera imposée
et ça c'est le cas depuis un moment et
ça sera le cas encore très très
longtemps tout simplement parce que je
préfère être rémunéré comme je l'avais
dit dans la vidéo où j'expliquais ça
pour ce que je produis mois à savoir les
formations à savoir les luttes les
précèdent à savoir des liens affiliés
éventuellement sur des produits que
j'aime mais je ne veux pas être un
panneau publicitaire et d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous dire que je vous fais
une petite promo là sur les formations
qui est en lien dans la description avec
un code donc vous pouvez y aller les
plaisirs et ça fait vivre la chaîne état
permet justement de garder
l'indépendance dans le propos est
d'avoir du temps pour vous filmer des
trucs cool vous soutenez la chaîne et en
plus de ça vous avez une contrepartie
tout le monde est content et ça ça
m'amène à l'avant dernier point qui est
le rapport à youtube qui a aussi changé
en 2021 je ne fais plus de vidéos pour
remplir pour avoir du contenu pour être
régulier ça vous avez bien pu le voir il
ya eu assez peu de vidéo cette année
grand max biaggi en avoir je sais plus
j'ai pas compté mais genre 15 entre 15
et 20 je dirais maximum est pas un
rythme de fou furieux quand on veut
faire fonctionner sa chaîne youtube et
cette année il ya eu bon par moments des
manques de temps il ya eu aussi des
vidéos qui on demandait beaucoup de
temps comme la websérie mais il ya
surtout eu le fait que je me suis dit je
fais des vidéos quand j'en ai envie
uniquement quand j'en ai envie et quand
j'ai un truc à dire qui va de pair dire
que je vais pas faire une vidéo à tien
j'aime la caméra juste envie de parler
pour rien dire et non j'ai fait des
vidéos cette année quand j'avais envie
de les faire et quand je pensais qu'il y
avait un truc intéressant que je me
disais ah ça serait bien de le partager
aux gens pensent que les gens vont
trouver une plus value dans ce que je
vais dire si je fais une vidéo sur ce
sujet là et c'est très très très
libérateur à c'est à dire que je me suis
totalement affranchie dans ma tête des
chiffres des contraintes de 2 to le
youtube games et tous âges et je vois là
je me suis senti un petit peu libéré là
dessus et ça c'est quelque chose que je
compte continuer de faire en 2022 c'est
à dire faire des vidéos quand j'ai un
truc intéressant à dire et point bas pas
juste pour remplir pour être régulier ou
pour mettre du contenu ou pour pas que
les gens n'oublient ou voilà juste quand
j'ai envie on arrive au dernier point le
point qui va fâcher un petit peu c'est
que cette année et ben c'est la première
année où j'ai vraiment eu des hits
heures des gens qui sont venus me
chercher un petit peu sur certaines
choses et je vais pas vous mettre les
échanges machin tout ça mais grosso modo
ça venait me chercher sur des choses que
les gens imaginaient notamment il ya eu
le fait qu' est-ce que je suis objectif
est ce que par exemple le fait que j'ai
fait une vidéo sur le z9 est-ce que
j'étais objectif dans ce que je disais
et clairement je vous ai expliqué
pourquoi oui j'étais objectif parce que
c'est pas ni connu qu'est venu le
chercher c'est moi qui serai leur dirai
je veux utiliser votre matos parce que
ça peut être cool mais je vais pas
m'étendre là dessus je vous en ai déjà
parlé il ya eu aussi des gens qui
pensaient que je disais des choses que
je ne disais pas et donc je sais que
vous qui regardez cette vidéo jusqu'à la
fin qui est des gens qui font partie de
la communauté vous pensez pas comme ça
mais moi je demande aux autres jamais
vous avez un doute sur mes intentions
sur ce que je dis sur tout ça c'est très
bien de douter il faut se méfier sur
internet de ce que disent les gens et de
ce que proposent les gens mais essayer
s'il vous plaît de ne pas aller chercher
des idées au delà de ce que je dis pas
ce que la plupart du temps je suis très
premier degré dans mes vidéos c'est à
dire que je dis sincèrement ce que je
pense je dis aussi régulièrement je me
considère pas comme le meilleur fait pas
forcément ce que je fais moi je fais
plein d'erreurs je voulais montre
souvent et je vous les montre pour
éviter de les refaire j'ai pas la
science infuse je suis pas le plus grand
youtuber de la planète sur le sujet que
je traite là je suis pas le plus grand
vidéaste non plus j'ai aucune prétention
là dessus mais je fais de mon mieux
j'essaie de m'améliorer toujours de
produire des choses cool it vous le
partagez et ça ça reste et ça restera
toujours le coeur de cette chaîne j'ai
un passé d'enseignant et j'aime partager
les choses j'aime transmettre j'aime
faire apprendre des choses aux gens et
ça c'est quelque chose qui durera
toujours ça l'a toujours été ça me sera
toujours mon objectif sur cette chaîne
il est de partager des choses avec vous
oui des fois il ya des deals avec des
marques mais je suis toujours
transparents dessus oui des fois je vous
propose d'acheter une formation je vous
propose d'acheter un bas de lutte où je
vous propose d'aller cliquer sur un lien
de traquer en description tout
simplement parce que tout ce que je fais
ici ça prend du temps et que m'a plu
j'ai du temps libre où j'ai pas besoin
d'aller chercher trop de contre à bas
tout ce temps là je peux le passé à
faire des vidéos pour youtube c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça il n'y a pas de
mauvaises intentions derrière il n'y a
pas d' arnaque derrière tout ça la
chaîne vous pouvez la consulter
gratuitement dans tous les cas on est
obligé de rien acheter je voulais pas
juste un truc ici et puis vous payez
pour aller voir la suite ou s'inscrire à
une newsletter ou machin c'est vraiment
très très très premier degré je l' ai
toujours été je le serai toujours et ça
c'est le point le plus important que je
voulais vous dire c'est ça qui va
continuer encore en 2022 et juste avant
de mettre le coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo si vous l'avez
aimée je vous souhaite de très bonnes
fêtes je vous souhaite un merveilleux
réveillon et je vous souhaite aussi une
très très très très bonne année 2022
qu'elle soit pleine vidéos qu'elles sont
pleines de découvertes plein de bonheur
et de fun et de kif et tout ce que vous
voulez et moi je vous dis les amis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo en 2022 ciao